>> MIHAILOVSKI: Hi, my name is Nick Mihailovski
and I'm going to quickly walk you through
the Google Analytics Treemap demo. In this
demo we get data from the Google Analytics
Google Data API and we return to the HTML
table. And that table is then visualized using
the Protovis SVG library into a real fancy
Treemap here. When you just get the data as
a table, here we're looking at rows and rows
of HTML data, about 500 rows here of Google
Analytics Data. We're looking at the different
pages that people came to visit at your website
and that's all the number of people who came
through that certain page. With this visualization
what we're able to do is visualize how many
entrances for a particular page is and how
many bounces that people came to this site.
And the bounces are one-page view visits.
And so, when you come to the site you only
see one page and you leave, we define it as
a bounce. And we calculate the bounce rate
as the total number of bounces divided by
entrances. And so, what this visualization
allows us to do is the larger boxes show us
pages that have higher traffic. You see this
You + Tube page has the most entrances at
55,000 while some of this much smaller pages
have much less. And so, the size of the box
represents the traffic, the color represents
the bounce rate. Generally, a low bounce is
good and what it's colored as green and red--a
higher bounce is bad and we color it as red.
And so, we've added some interaction here
with some JQuery in so that way you can filter
out different pages that have high entrances.
And so that way you can make the smaller entrances
larger. And so, quickly we can come in here
and say this was green and this page here
has a low bounce rate, 8.5% to 4%. This page
here also had a low bounce rate, 1.36%. But
then let's look at some of the red and we
can quickly see this page had a 90.7%. And
so, it's a quick way to take a boring HTML
table and transform it to something really
beautiful using Protovis, JQuery and SVG.